be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about DC's Kingdom Come and
what I'm hoping is that by the end of
all of this you'll have an understanding
of why this story was written and why so
many consider it to be one of the best
DC stories ever told
the solid story of Kingdom Come actually
has its roots in the Marvel Comics story
Marvel's written by Kurt Busiek and John
by Alex Ross were Marvel stories usually
take place from the perspective of the
superhero or super villain involved
Marvel's took place from the perspective
of a normal human named Phil Sheldon as
he chronicled the actions of superheroes
from world war ii up until the 1980s in
a 2006 interview with wizard
entertainment Alex Ross had stated that
during his time working on Marvel's the
idea came to him to expand this concept
to DC Comics following his departure
from Marvel in 1996 Alex Ross followed
through with this idea alongside writer
Mark Waid by introducing the four-part
story kingdom come like all titles
published under the DC Elseworlds banner
Kingdom Come focuses on DC superheroes
outside of any previously established
continuity and exists as a
self-contained story following a
religious minister named Norma Kaye who
was created explicitly for this story
Kingdom Come sinners on a world where
DC's iconic heroes find themselves
wrapped up in a civil war against the
new generation of heroes which brings a
world to the brink of complete
destruction
so the story of Kingdom Come picks up
with Norman McCay as he's reading
biblical scripture to a man named Wesley
Dodds as one of DCs older superheroes
dating back to 1939 and the normal DC
continuity Wesley Dodds goes by the name
of Sandman and has prophetic dreams that
allow him to see crimes that criminals
will commit before they happen
armed with a gun that emits a sleeping
gas of sorts Wesley Dodds would subdue
criminals and take them in as they were
preparing to commit their crime but
before they could act however in the
Kingdom Come series Wesley Dodds is
dying of old age but has apocalyptic
visions of the world's end while these
visions aren't necessarily clear what
Wesley is able to discern is that this
apocalypse will come about as a result
of a superhuman civil war while Wesley
attempts to alert Norman of the
impending disaster
Norman considers these to be largely due
to Wesley experiencing bouts of insanity
or hallucinations as a result of being
near-death and so as the story continues
Norman gives us an explanation of the
world as it exists at the time and what
we're told is that the heroes of all
that is to say Superman Batman Wonder
Woman and the rest of DCs top tier
heroes have basically left in their
place exists a new breed of hero
engaging in battles with one another and
with villains without any regard for the
safety of citizens as a result these
battles are often violent ending with
massive property destruction and
casualties while the reason behind why
these heroes of old are no longer acting
is left ambiguous the backstories
provided when Nolan McKay receives a
visit from the spectre while this is a
character that we've never discussed the
spectre exists as the hand of God in DC
Comics carrying out his will and
punishing those who have been judged
accordingly to this end the spectre
selects Norman McCay to assist in
judging the superheroes of Earth to
determine who should be allowed to live
and who should be allowed to die a
taking us on a journey the spectre and
Norma Kaye revealed that 10 years prior
the Joker had murdered 93 people at the
Daily Planet including Jimmy Olsen and
Lois Lane while the Joker was captured
by authorities on the day of his trial
he was murdered by a vigilante named
Magog because of the gruesome nature of
the Joker's crime coupled with society's
desire is he justice done rather than
calling for Magog to be held accountable
for his act humanity praised him for
what they perceived as a willingness to
do what needed to be done
realizing that humanity seemed to cast
aside its desire for justice and instead
embraced vigilantism sibrand walked away
leaving the human community to deal with
Magog and its undisciplined heroes that
were inspired to act in the same
vigilante tactics furthermore because
Superman was viewed as an icon among so
many heroes in the DC Universe
individuals like Aquaman Alan Scott the
Green Lantern of Earth as well as others
abandon their roles of superheroes and
retreated to lives of solitude however
when a group of heroes and villains
engage in a battle on one of the bridges
of Metropolis Superman arrives having
apparently abandoned his solitude and
returned to restore order to the world
so from here the story temporarily
shifts away from the perspective of
normal decay and focuses on Superman
what we learn is that during the time in
which Superman was in solitude he was
approached by Wonder Woman in an effort
to coach Superman back into action when
a woman had him watched newsreels on the
effects of damages that have been taking
place in Kansas during a conflict
between parasite and Magog along with
his forces Magog had expressed an
unnecessary amount of violence the
result was that one of the super heroes
was effectively ripped open due to the
fact that his body was composed of a
litany of atoms which basically made him
an atomic bomb this set off a massive
explosion and resulted in the complete
destruction of Kansas as an entirety as
well as the surrounding states of
Nebraska Iowa and Missouri from here the
story switches back to the present and
with Superman as he begins to rally
former heroes together in an effort to
confront and in the reign of Magog while
Superman is able to bring together the
flash power girl Hawkman Wonder Woman
and others the one person missing from
this lineup and perhaps the most
important piece of the puzzle is Batman
a visiting Bruce Wayne in what's left of
Wayne Manor
Bruce reveals that the mansion was
attacked by the combined efforts of
two-phase and Bane following Superman's
departure and the implementation of
lawlessness in the United States
in addition Arkham Asylum Blackgate
prison and Belle Reve prison were all
destroyed with his inmates either
escaping or being killed in the process
while Superman attempts to enlist the
aid of Batman Bruce Wayne states that he
has no intention of joining Superman the
reason for this is because a superhuman
population exploded after Superman left
rather than staying on and being a role
model for these new heroes in order
teach them the manner in which they
should operate and to confront foes and
preserve order a Superman allowed them
to become feral with no true
understanding of what it means to be
heroes but furthermore Batman argues
that Superman's position will only
incite more violence because he is
effectively imposing his will on other
heroes and so rather than taking a
stance of physical force Batman
suggested Superman take a more
diplomatic role and so with both sides
at a complete stalemate
Superman departs and following this
Batman reveals that Oliver Queen Black
Canary and others exist as a sort of
team serving the purpose of providing
Batman with information on the world
outside of Gotham at this point the
story begins to spiral out of control
while Superman makes his efforts to
acquire as many heroes as possible
Batman does the same operating as
opposing forces
Superman's approach of attempting to
force heroes to join the Justice League
results in massive rebellions and
several battles placing those who
refused to convert into a prison
established in the middle of Kansas a
Superman finds that there are actually
more prisoners than there are free
heroes on the planet Earth conversely
Batman allies himself with Lex Luthor
forming a coalition to mass-produce
robots that are capable of fighting
these superheroes and quell all super
human activity on earth and so the
conflict between the two groups both
Batman and Superman as well as humanity
and supervillains comes to a head when a
riot breaks out at the Kansas prison
with super humans fighting one another
and with minimal protection the Justice
League rallies in an effort to stop the
ride and restore order
however willfully outmatched by sheer
numbers Superman's attempts to do what
he can is met with the arrival of Shazam
and transitioning back to Nolan McKay
inspector we get this incredible
dialogue as Norman watches the massive
battle
fold with all parties involved realizing
that this could very well mean the end
of the world
Norman describes its scene in incredible
detail analyzing Superman's predicament
and discussing his confusion on how
things could have gotten this bad what
Norman realizes is that despite
Superman's vast powers in the conflict
and desire to bring order to the world
the Superman failed to realize that
leadership is just as much about
diplomacy as it is about physical force
the new generation of heroes founded
under Magog are a group that are
inherently evil and instead they're
simply undisciplined raised in a world
that was unable to differentiate between
justice and vigilantism the new breed of
heroes were simply emulating the actions
of the only true role model they had and
so with Batman's forces joining the fray
and the line between hero and vigilante
becoming ever blurred and their panic
humanity launches a nuclear warhead at
the battle site at this point we
transition to the specter presenting one
of the best questions in the entire
story The Spectre instructional men to
choose who will be judged if the bomb is
stalked by Superman the super humans
will live but their existence will lead
to a war that will destroy the earth
eventually however if the bomb has not
stopped humanity will survive but super
heroes will be wiped out in their
entirety while either choice will
present a genocide The Spectre tells
Norma Kay to choose who is responsible
for this entire situation humanity or
the superhumans now what I want to do is
I want to take a break away from the
story for a second and the reason why is
because I think this is one of the most
important moments in the story because
an argument can be made on both sides
while this is a battle of superhumans
and Superman could have taken a
different approach that would have
prevented this from happening
at the same time humanity chose to
allied so for the vigilante failing to
notice that magog's actions weren't a
willingness to do what needed to be done
in support of humanity but instead they
were done in spite of humanity now tell
me back in two things
the sentiment of Norma Kay is further
expanded on when Superman stops the
battle between himself and Shazam
realizing that the nuclear blast will
kill all those present safer only a
handful of individuals a Superman
instructions am to make a decision
because she's a mess human alter ego is
billy batson allowing him to live as
both superhuman and normal human Eva
Shazam can stop Superman and allow the
bomb to drop or Shazam could allow super
to stop the bomb choosing a third option
Shazaam incapacitate Superman intercepts
the bomb and detonates it killing
himself in the process and so in the
ensuing destruction and believing
himself to be the sole survivor
Superman travels to the United Nations
bent on revenge and punishing humanity
for the decision to kill so many people
competing with the spectre to take him
to intervene Noah McKay arrives and
talks Superman down stating that
Superman allowed his grief over the
death of Lois Lane and humanity's
willingness to cast out justice to
basically drive him away is somewhere on
the lines to go and forgot that more
important than any hero or human is a
sanctity of life realizing the value in
Norman's words Superman relents and so
as a story begins to come to a close
Superman states that were previously
they had operated in a manner that
imposed their will on humanity instead
they will simply lead humanity in the
hopes that this new era will create a
lasting peace on the planet Earth
the so following its release keenham
come was met with universal acclaim
praise for his artwork and philosophical
look at the traditional role of
superheroes
Kingdom Come is considered one of the
greatest DC stories of all time in a
review published in 2013 the comics
authority points out that the beauty of
Kingdom Come is that it points to
everything that's both amazing and
complicated about the DC Universe in
praising Mark Twain's latticework of
intermingling plots and presenting a
confrontation between Batman and
Superman composed of ideals rather than
physical battles the comic Authority
sums up the story quite well in stating
that Kingdom Come presents a series of
events reminding Earth's heroes that the
responsibility is not to protect humans
or engage in self gratification it's
simply to inspire hope with that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it and I
won't catch you guys later peace